l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines versailles grand parc et paris
saclay tous réunis au centre du même
stand à l'occasion du salon de
l'immobilier d'entreprise
le but attirer les investisseurs le but
c'est à nous faire partager au plus
grand nombre pour que les investisseurs
est immédiatement envie de s'installer
sur paris saclay et plus principalement
sur un ca grand paris là nous c'est un
moyen un bon vecteur de communication
des changes
et puis en trois jours en fait on peut
largement optimisé ce rendez vous tous
les territoires franciliens sont
présents aussi mis pour michel laugier
président de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son agglomération a toute sa place au
sein du simi grâce aux forces qu'elles
possèdent les forces de 50 ha déjà c'est
que
c'est une agglomération qui existent et
qui a beaucoup de qualités
pour rappel 235 mille habitants 140
chanel emploie 5600 crise et surtout
donc soit l'issue d'une ville nouvelle
dent depuis plus de 40 ans de tour soit
150 1 dont nous savons ce que c'est que
la déneigement et donc les promoteurs
qui sont là
bien sûr sont toujours intéressés par
d'autres territoires il reste que
attractif
une servante vu ce qu'ils ont à faire
vamara des personnes qui d'autriche bien
les choses c'est la première fois que
l'agglomération de paris-saclay
participent à l'événement le simi est
donc un enjeu important pour eux il
souhaite faire découvrir leurs projets
j'entends parler du plateau de saclay
qu'un projet et hommage aux structures
en mai découdre sur notre sens d autres
opportunités puisque nous avons
soixantaine zone d'activité économique à
l'échelle du territoire
donc il ya un contre majorque
structurants mis à tout ce qui est
autour qui offre des capacités
meetic sur un territoire étendu avec des
capacités pour accueillir les petites
entreprises
l'artisanat la pme qui par définition
est également les grilles tout
plusieurs conférences sont à prévoir
lors du simi l'événement ferme ses
portes le vendredi 2 décembre 2016